we are told fill in the table with whole
numbers to make ten point seven four in
two different ways so pause this video
and see if you can figure that out so we
really need to fill out what would be
what would you put in here for this to
be a representation of ten point seven
four all right now let's do it together
and I'm going to rewrite the number a
little bit larger so that we can really
inspect the place values so one way to
think about it is we have zero ones and
then we have one ten but they don't
express it that way they don't say one
ten and zero ones up here they just say
ten ones but that's reasonable so when
they're saying ten ones here
they are referring to those ten ones or
you could view that as one ten and zero
ones either way you have ten ones and
then if you move one decimal place over
this seven tenths well that makes sense
you have a seven in the tenths place and
then this four hundredths makes sense
you have four in the hundredths place
but now let's see what they're doing
over here so once again they're saying
no tens but ten ones so that is actually
the same we could say one ten and zero
ones or we could say ten once and now
over here they've reduced the number of
tenths and you're like hey what's going
on I have there's looks like there's
seven tenths here but one way to think
about it is they're regrouping from one
place to another and so what they've
done is they've taken that extra tenth
and they've put it someplace and the
only other place they could put it is in
the hundreds place so if I were to take
a tenth from the tenths place a tenth is
worth ten hundredths so one way to think
about it is they're taking a tenth from
there so now this is going to be this is
going to be six tenths and if you where
you're going to put that tenth well you
could put it in the hundredths place but
a tenth is going to be ten hundredths so
if you had ten hundredths to the four
hundredths that are already there well
that is going to give you 14 hundredths
so we would put a 14 right over
let's do another example just to really
make sure we're understanding what's
going on so once again they say fill in
the table with whole numbers to make
five point four in three different ways
so pause this video and see if you can
have a go at it alright so I'm gonna
rewrite the number so we have five point
four and in this first row this is maybe
the most standard way or traditional way
of interpreting five point four in our
ones place you have a five and you see
that five ones and in our tenths place
we have a four and that's what they have
right over here for tens what are they
doing in this second row well they're
saying 24 tenths 24 tenths so somehow in
one way to think about it in the tenths
place they were they were able to add 20
tenths so they went from four tenths to
24 tenths so if you're adding 20 tenths
here they must have taken it away from
some other place 20 tenths is the same
thing as two ones so they must have
taken two ones away from here so they
took two ones away from here so this
would be three ones and now 24 tenths so
we could put a three right over there
and you can verify that 24 tenths is the
same thing as two holes and or two ones
and four tenths or two point four two
point four plus three is going to be
equal to five point four all right so
here we only have one one and so what
happened to the other four ones well
they must have been transferred to the
tenths place so let me rewrite the
number so if we were to take four ones
away from the ones place so we're taking
four away from this you only have one
left
and what would happen if I transfer
those four ones to the tenths place well
then they would be 40 tenths four ones
are forty tenths so we would add 40 to
40 tenths over here so we already have
4/10
so this would become 44 tents 44 tents
and we're done